well here's the surprise James guns the
Suicide Squad might just feature a big
bad who is well pretty big and pretty
bad rumor slinging website we got this
covered
is reporting that their Osso and anima
sources tell them that the main villain
of the upcoming soft reboot will be none
other than Vandal Savage an iconic DC
villain with a very long history the
gang being assembled for the Suicide
Squad is an interesting mix of the
familiar and the new Margot Robbie will
be repricing her role as Harley Quinn
arguably the star of the show the first
time around also returning or Viola
Davis is Amanda Waller Joel Kinnaman is
team leader Rick Flagg and Jai Courtney
is Captain Boomerang new to the
proceedings this time around our David
dish mulch in is polkadot man daniela
Melchior as a gender flipped version of
the criminal known as rat catcher and
steve agee as the voice of king shark a
slew of famous names have also been cast
in undisclosed roles although John Cena
is widely believed to be taken on the
role of peacemaker a vigilante so
stridently committed to the cause of
peace that he'll straight-up kill you if
you aren't also among the cast or idris
elba storm read Nathan Fillion Michael
Rooker Peter Capaldi and Taika Waititi
plot rumors suggest that the movie will
see Waller sending in the Suicide Squad
to deal with some kind of alien beast
that has been held captive in a secret
prison built by the Nazis during the
Second World War this monster is now
under the sway of two villains referred
to in the synopsis only as the mayor and
the general these rather official
sounding names may indeed hint at savage
as in the pages of DC Comics the villain
has played a part in world events
throughout all of history savage came
into the world as an actual caveman but
was granted a powerful intellect in
immortality by a mysterious radioactive
meteorite that fell to earth in his
vicinity he's basically been playing the
governments and societies of the world
like a fiddle for roughly 50 thousand
years and it suggested that he may have
taken on the mantle of a wide array of
different historical figures Oh
mandis been revered as a god and exalted
as a ruler by multiple civilizations
throughout history so yeah how's that
for a big bad obviously it needs to be
said that this rumor should be taken
with about six pounds of salt we got
this covered is hardly the most reliable
source of inside info and while the site
has filled that accurate
rumor reports in the past it has also
fielded more than its fair share of
complete funk it should also be pointed
out that the plot synopsis has in no way
being confirmed and that Gunn himself
has said that a good deal of the rumors
floating about concerning the suicide
squad are untrue there have also been a
good number of other baddies rumored for
the film other inside sources have
asserted for example that Capaldi will
be portraying frequent Teen Titans
antagonist Simon while some have
insisted that the alien monster
mentioned in the synopsis will be none
other than John Jones also known as
Martian Manhunter until Gunn decides to
give fans some inside info or even a
trailer all of this should be taken as
pure speculation the truth is nobody
outside of the production yet knows who
the suicide squads main antagonist will
be well almost nobody that is speaking
on his fat man beyond podcast last June
filmmaker and quintessential comic book
geek Kevin Smith revealed that he is in
fact privy to that particular
information Smith asked his audience if
they had heard the news about the movies
villain and when nobody responded in the
affirmative he admitted he had figured
everyone knew already because I thought
everybody knew and I was about to say oh
my god they're gonna and then I was like
wait I might have heard you say to break
something I'm happy who mighta heard
that privately unfortunately Smith was
reluctant to spill any details about
what he'd heard but what he did say was
pretty encouraging if it is what I heard
it is phenomenal and it boy is it in the
right hands oh well then bring on August
20 21 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you